so Jonathan good evening to you is it
fair to say lot of this is down to
people buying David Bowie and George
Michael records after they passed away
absolutely and that's note and that
that's a great thing but one shouldn't
forget we have some of the biggest
artists in the world at the moment Ed
Sheeran
Sam Smith Coldplay Radiohead they're
very much hard at storm Z they're very
much artists that are alive and I think
music should be enjoyed by all people of
all age groups from all generations and
it's fantastic people still by Elvis
Presley records still people still by
Beatles records so why shouldn't they
buy a Maui and George Michael records
what is British music such a success
tour I mean you know you go all the way
back to the Beatles the Rolling Stones
the WHO all the way through to the
present day and the artists you've just
described and what is it about British
music I think creatively I'm not just
British music for this film British
television British theatre British
musical you just said we hit well above
our weight in the UK we're an
outward-looking country we export a
great deal and we are the most important
language in the world being English the
great advantage we have is America's
very insular so America looks internally
whereas Britain that looks outwardly so
you have a much bigger advantage but the
most important thing is we have I think
the best creative people in the world in
Britain what's also very striking though
Jonathan is see um the record industry
the music industry recycles about a
quarter of its profits in ANR trying to
discover new artists I mean if you if
you look at that it's it's version of
R&D that's about twice the level of say
the pharmaceutical industry isn't it and
it's absolutely in it and the replica
industries the music and this should be
credited the way they reinvest
themselves because the major record
companies do we reinvest in artists
hence why you've got Adele Samson Smith
edge here and if countries didn't
reinvest you wouldn't have them and
coming forward with companies like
relentless have got fantastic arts like
Nadia Rose you've got great artists to
the future who are being developed now
and the British music industry really
looks forward in America if you look at
the American charts
you've got continual groups that remain
that came big ten fifteen years ago
whereas the UK creates new creative
product continually
I'm very key in the music industry but
one mustn't forget we have great film
talent we have great television for
talent we have great theater talent
Britain really is the capital creative
city of the world briefly Jonathan is it
as lucrative a career as it once was I
mean recorded music sales aren't as
strong as they used to be the musicians
are having to go out more on tour to
make money is it quite as profitable of
business as it was once for the
individual artists well it's interesting
you say that because of course recorded
music has been down but we're streaming
it's now worth six hundred and ten
million in the UK a year interesting
enough the live music industry in the UK
is worth over nine hundred million so
that gives you an example of the ratio
of live versus recorded but we're
streaming streaming digital streaming
has opened up the market and a
completely new way to people although
okay Jonathan got to cut your firm
afraid thanks very much for joining me
Jonathan Charlotte you're welcome